- [Interviewer] All right, Maria.
Maria, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Maria] Boyle Heights.
- [Interviewer] So East LA?
East LA is a whole different ball game.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
And tell me about your family.
Are both of your parents growing up?
- I don't have my father,
but I have a great mom,
you know, like every other mother.
You know, she struggled to make anything
possible for her kids, you know?
And my father was a great father,
but, you know, God took him so soon,
so I didn't have a father after
the age of five, you know?
So, you know, I kind
of grew up in the hood,
in the barrio.
I learned the dope game,
and it was easy to, from there,
just to get money from guys.
- [Interviewer] So you matured fast.
- Yeah. It was way faster.
- [Interviewer] 'Cause
you told me your age,
and I have a hard time believing it.
How old are you?
- I don't wanna say my age.
Okay. You told me a very young age.
- I don't wanna say my age, you know?
- [Interviewer] Understood.
How would you describe your childhood?
- Kind of rough. You know what I'm saying?
But it was easy to fall into it on my end,
because, you know,
without a father figure,
trying to, you know,
help you, you know,
stay in the right place.
You know, my mom taught me how,
you know, to do things a little different.
So I liked it.
I'm not gonna sit here and lie.
I was so immune to that life.
It was ridiculous.
Like, I'm even in it right now,
still, you know?
It's kind of hard to detach yourself
from something you got so
immune and adapted to, you know?
Rolling with certain age group that,
you know, it's something that was not
of a normal type of life, you know?
- [Interviewer] You left home at what age?
- Age of 10, 11.
You know what I'm saying?
- Where do you go at 10 or 11?
I used to always be at my friends' houses.
I never stayed at home.
You know, I would come
home when I wanted to.
My mom, she would complain,
but what can she do?
You know, I was a adolescence
type of child, you know?
Always wanting to do what I wanna do,
and that's how it's gonna be,
because she showed me that
this is okay, you know?
So I ran with it,
and decided to do it on my own terms,
and you know, went back home,
and try to make it, you know, work.
And there was times that, you know,
I just didn't like to
bother with my family,
so leave again.
You know, it's easy to run the streets.
Nobody can tell you what to do.
You do what you wanna do
and how you wanna do it.
My life hasn't been so easy, you know?
But it's good right now.
I'm already immune to, you know?
Once you get ahold of how you're gonna do
what you wanna do on the streets,
nobody else can tell you anything.
- [Interviewer] And where do you live now?
You're in Skid Row?
- Somewhat, because I really
do have a place to go.
I choose not to,
because I have a choice of drug,
and I have to get what I need,
how I need to get it.
- [Interviewer] So by staying down here,
you're close to your supply?
- Yeah, of course.
- And what's your drug?
- Crack cocaine, you know?
And I know if my kids are
watching this, I apologize,
but it is what it is, you know?
It's reality.
I do intend to stop,
but just right now it's
not the time, you know?
I'm still immune to this life.
- [Interviewer] What age were you
when you started using crack?
- At the age of 13.
And I'm not gonna say no more of that,
'cause I know you're trying
to get my age out of me.
- No, no, no.
- It's not gonna work.
- [Interviewer] Who turned
you onto crack at 13?
- I did.
- [Interviewer] You take
responsibility for it.
- Yes, I do.
You know, I had an abusive
over-age boyfriend at that time,
and he still abused me a lot,
like beat me, you know,
besides the abuse of
sexual that I had younger,
but you know, the trauma,
and the messed up brain that I had,
you know, I said, you know,
I wonder what it feels to
make him do what he does,
but I didn't know it was
in time of using the drug.
That is how you develop it, you know?
'Cause in the beginning it
wasn't like the way I am now,
you know, in the beginning,
everything's dandy.
You know what I'm saying?
Everything goes so quick.
In the rougher parts of the rollercoaster,
should I say,
things are not always beautiful.
You know what I'm saying?
There's people that may be
in denial for themselves,
but I'm not.
I'm not ashamed,
because I know that I probably
have hurt a lot of my,
you know, real close, loved ones,
and I didn't intend to.
It's just something that happened
with the choices I've
done and made, you know?
And sometimes I wish
I could turn back time
and do things a little different,
and sometimes it just happens
the way it happens, you know?
And I know the ones that love you the most
are always gonna stick there.
So I just have like less than a handful
of people that I can honestly say love me
and still are here with me,
regardless of my addiction,
regardless of what I've
been through or put them.
They give me my space
and they're waiting for
me to be ready on my term.
And I respect that now.
You know, before I didn't,
because I didn't want to.
I thought they were trying
to just hold me back,
and not, you know,
oh my God, control my life,
but I understood that, you know,
when you're ready to change,
it's gonna be within self,
not nobody else's terms, you know?
And the streets are not no joke,
but I take 'em, you know?
I take risks.
I have been raped,
abused, physically, mentally, sexually,
being out here in these streets, you know?
And I still don't know how
I intend to still smoke,
or do what I have to do.
I'm not gonna say the other,
but everybody should know.
You know what I'm saying?
Ain't nobody that has their right mind
not know what I'm speaking of.
But as I'm saying, it's
the truth, you know?
You are grown,
you do things that you have to do
by any means necessary to
get what you need to get,
to be okay or numb for the moment.
You know what I'm saying?
For whatever situation
you're going through,
or however you have to
handle it, you escape.
People say, "Oh no, you're
this and you're that."
And it's not that,
it's just 'cause it's true.
You might just have that trauma
that really beats you in.
You have to numb yourself
to get okay for yourself.
You know, a lot of people
don't understand that.
Some people's ways of doing things
are not the same as others.
And a lot of people in
life seem to judge people
instead of trying to help
us or be our support.
You know what I'm saying?
To help us get off slowly,
or however we have to get off, you know?
'Cause it ain't easy for me. I tried it.
It didn't work.
I tried to do it for self like twice,
and another situation occurred,
and I ran again.
You know, I'm a chronic user.
- [Interviewer] You've been
to rehabs and stuff like that?
- Yes I have.
I've even been to prison.
I've been to jail.
- [Interviewer] So prison
and jail gets you clean.
- Yeah. For the moment.
Don't get it twisted,
for the time that you're in there, yes,
and you will say anything,
because there you feel sane.
There you feel like you have to be clean.
There's no other choice.
You could get high, don't get me twisted,
but you think you're
gonna really wanna waste
all your money on getting high,
when you already know you
gained a lot of weight,
you're healthy and you're thinking right?
And you're controlled
by the time that you
have to do everything.
You're not like in this
free world. It's not easy.
You know what I'm saying?
'Cause us chronic users that know
that we run from the drama,
or the hurt,
or the pain that we go through,
or whatever, you know?
And we don't wanna feel,
we're gonna go and run to
where we're comfortable.
And it's easy,
'cause when you go to
your stomping grounds,
where you know it's
easy to get it like this
without even having money,
it's more easier to just numb it and go in
and just get on the roller
coaster and not get off.
You know, like, "No, let me keep on going.
Let everybody else get on with me."
And that's how it feels,
literally it does.
'Cause there's gonna be times
where you're gonna go up,
you're gonna go down,
and you're gonna take
that circle, you know?
And some people don't like to admit it.
I have integrity. I'm accepting
everything I go through.
- [Interviewer] You take
responsibility for it?
- Yeah, I do.
- That's great. That's rare.
- You know what I'm saying?
Because nobody's making me.
I ran to it. I am the one that went to it.
Nobody else did it for me?
- [Interviewer] Your
mom wasn't at it, right?
- At one point, yes.
She stopped after a
certain amount of time,
and she tried to, you know, show me,
but I told her, "You still can't show me,"
because I have to be able to say, "Okay."
I have to be the one good with it.
I have to be the one to know that it's me,
the reason why I'm stopping,
because I can't do it for you.
I can't do it for my grandma.
I can't do it for none of my babies.
And I can't do it for
my significant other,
if I would have one.
But right now I'm doing it,
because I have went
through a lot of trauma,
and right I'm like facing...
I have to go, you know,
to court on a rape charge that
somebody did to me, you know?
And I fear, you know?
Who of his family may be
at there at that courtroom?
You know what I'm saying?
Will they do something to me,
or to my family?
Or do they know where I stay?
That's why I do all this,
because I'm scared, I'm nervous.
I don't know if he does
know people or he doesn't.
He might be the one in jail,
but how do I know his people
ain't capable of doing something
for having him go in there, you know?
There's people that is
crazy in this world.
And you know, I'll test the water, but,
you know, I don't know
if he's gonna be my last,
or if my kids won't be able
to see me no more, you know?
So that's why--
- [Interviewer] You think
that's why a lot of women
don't say anything?
'Cause there's repercussions if you do?
- Yeah.
And sometimes--
- [Interviewer] Not just from the police,
if you're a sex worker,
but on the street.
- I'm gonna tell you, it
is scary in the street.
You know what I'm saying?
When a person either sticks a
knife to your head or a gun,
you know, and they're raping you,
you know, you don't even
know if it's the last moment
you're gonna live, you know?
And it is scary.
It's something powerful
that you just don't understand, you know?
And it's something that's kind of,
you know, you have to
just either take the risk
or go and high, you know?
And numb yourself,
so you know that you're
safe and you're okay.
So, you know,
that's the type of things
that people don't understand,
what's the hurt in the things that we do
in the streets, you know?
Straight up, they don't.
But even though that has happened to me,
it's made me a stronger woman
and understand that taking responsibility
is something that's okay.
It's okay to surrender
and know that it's, you know, nothing bad.
Who cares if the next
person talks about you?
They really not doing nothing
for you or your habit, you know?
- [Interviewer] Has living
this lifestyle changed you,
made you stronger?
- It has.
But it has made me think too,
like, I do wanna stop.
I don't know when is the time.
But some people tell me
when I try to get advice
from other people, they tell me,
"You don't know.
You don't know the moment
because you'll leave.
Then the moment you leave,
you'll know you're done."
So I guess then I will know.
But right now I'm still not ready.
You know, straight up. I'm not.
- [Interviewer] Do you have family members
and things like that
trying to get you to quit?
- They just say, "When you're ready," now.
Now they know,
so they don't try to pressure
me or get me to go home,
because they know that
if they do that, I run,
and they don't wanna do that.
They just want me to come by myself.
So they say, "When you're ready,
you know, your house is here.
Come whenever you want."
- [Interviewer] One of the
best things I've heard,
somebody who works at a rehab said that,
"When an addict's ready to
quit, no one can stop them.
But when an attic isn't ready to quit,
no one can make them."
- I know, and they can't,
because even my mom,
I have her phone,
'cause a couple of days back
I got drugged and raped,
and they stole my other
phone my mom bought me,
just to keep in contact with me.
I don't know why the people did it.
I didn't know them.
And you know, I thought
I was safe with them.
Little do you know,
your own race can do
so much damage to you.
And people are talking about criticism
of other races, like Blacks
and Whites and Asians,
or whatever,
but your own kind can
get you too, you know?
And it was a heroin addict
that did that to me,
and a female at that.
She set me up with her own
friends so I can get raped.
It's kind of scary thing, you know?
You think that you have
somebody you can trust,
and that person betrays you.
She gave me the date rape
drug in a liquid form,
in a cigarette,
and I didn't know.
And when I woke up,
I knew it was something weird,
'cause I didn't wake up with any shoes,
my bag, my phones,
everything was gone.
But I had bad aches on my body.
They raped me,
they even had the nerve
to put my pants back
exactly the way they were,
but I didn't have shoes on.
But probably my body was hurting
because I was fighting
back without knowing,
you know, consciously.
But I was gone.
My mind didn't allow me to see or feel.
You know, and the weirdest
thing that I know,
like God exists, should I say,
'cause I woke up at a church,
like the back steps of a church,
and I didn't know, you know?
And I always say that God has,
no matter what, he's kept me alive.
So I know that I'm not meant to die yet,
but I still don't wanna
live all my life, until,
like, you know,
the day that I die is the
last day I'm gonna get high.
I do wanna have a better life.
I do wanna get out of downtown.
I do wanna get my children back, you know?
And I want my life back.
- How old are you kids?
(Maria laughs)
- [Maria] I don't wanna
say their age, but--
- [Interviewer] Do you talk your kids?
- [Maria] Right now, no,
because the oldest one
she's kind of upset at me,
but it's okay.
She has every right now, you know?
She doesn't understand,
but she will one day, she will.
She will one day, because that day
that she gets to understand
or she even gets to see this,
she'll understand that her
mom wasn't okay up here,
and neither here, you know, herself,
but she tried the best she could.
- [Interviewer] Is that what you think
most people that don't use drugs,
perhaps maybe they
don't understand about--
- [Maria] Yeah, they don't.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] It's not
like you made a decision
to try drugs.
- No, it was just something that...
Someone was beating me,
and he would only beat me on this drug,
but I didn't know he was
using that drug till after,
when my mother said something about it,
and then I said, "Well, wow.
That's the reason?
I'm gonna try it."
So I found a way to get
it, which wasn't hard.
I did it.
And it was over, you know?
But my mom didn't always use it
until like later on, you know?
- [Interviewer] It also numbs
the pain of what happened
in your childhood?
- Yeah.
You know, a family member of mine,
you know, I was only five years old after,
you know, my father had died,
that that person started abusing me,
without any of my family believing me.
And seven years I kept my
mouth shut. Seven years.
And there's times I don't
remember anything he did to me,
but I remember the beginning,
but never the end,
just remember walking out the room.
And it bothers me,
because I always wanna remember,
and it beats me up inside,
because I can't remember, you know?
It's kind of hard.
It's like looking for something,
and you're trying to find it,
and you think you're gonna locate it,
and you can't,
because there's like a big gap
that will not allow you to get
to where you need to get to.
You know, and it's kind of like,
you try this way and that way,
and you try to view it and see it.
No, there's no way,
because your mind blocks it.
I guess the only way
that I can find out is,
like, they say the hypnosis or whatever,
but I don't even wanna know that,
because, probably, that
pain that he made me suffer,
I don't wanna, you know,
but it all started
'cause of him, you know?
And I never had the nerve
to, you know, voice it.
And sometimes I say that's
why I'm this screwed up.
You know?
But I guess I've forgiven him now,
and I just don't associate with him.
I don't bother with him.
He's in my family still.
I choose not to no more,
not even be around his
kids or my aunt, you know?
I just keep them away.
I stay as far as I can.
I try not to cross paths at all with him,
'cause he's damaged me a lot.
And I couldn't even believe
my aunt never believed me,
but it's okay.
I guess there's a big God,
and in his time he will
do what he has to do
and go through, you know?
So it's okay.
Life is cool for right now,
but I don't know.
Whenever I'm ready.
Hopefully I'm not like 70
when I'm long and ready
to change, you know?
I hope it's sooner than that.
You know, just for those
that don't understand,
try to put yourself in a
position where you can view it.
You don't have to be in a person's shoes,
but view it from a different angle,
and a different perspective,
and try to understand a person's hurt,
their damaged mind,
or, you know, try to support somebody
that is in a situation like mine,
so you guys don't have to misjudge them
or mislead them into something they don't,
you know, don't know how
to get out of as well,
because that could be damaging too,
when you're judging a person
that that's sick already
in their head,
and numbing themselves.
So yeah, you know, life ain't pretty,
but we seem to control
ourselves and know ourselves
in our own little world, should we say,
so I think it's good.
It's not nothing bad.
It's just, some people chose to live,
I went to college,
and bachelor's and master's, and all that,
and that's okay too, you know?
And, well, I think I
graduated from the streets.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what I say.
I got my bachelor's out here, you know?
But 'cause there is
things in the streets too,
if you don't know a certain level,
they treat you a little different.
So the same way a normal life is,
the same way is the streets.
So only certain people can tell,
if they've been in our shoes.
And I think that's it (laughs).
- [Interviewer] All right, Maria.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You're a great speaker.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Good luck.
- [Maria] Thank you.